So, several years ago, I was in a brand new apartment.
I woke up in the middle of the night to do something.
I don't remember what it was.
As I went back to bed, I rammed my toe so hard
into the bed frame that I ended up breaking my toe.
I didn't know I broke it until I woke up the next morning.
It was black and blue. My whole foot was all messed up.
And I limped around for days. The doctor told me there was nothing that could be
done about it because I just simply broke my toe.
The bed wasn't new, but the apartment was.
And when I woke up, it was pitch black.
I couldn't see a thing.
So naturally, I was so disoriented, didn't know where I was, didn't know what was
going on, that I forgot where the bed was because I forgot where I was.
Now see, growing up in my younger days as an early baby Christian,
that's kind of how I thought of faith.
I thought of faith as sort of this wandering in the darkness, trying to figure
something out, hoping that I don't stub my toe and hope I don't do something kind of
dumb.
And in reality, in my life, I actually did stub my toe to the point where I walked
away for quite some time. And as I came back to the church, I realized
something that faith is not at all like wandering in the darkness.
And what I've discovered is that so many students still kind of have that belief
that it's just either attaching themselves to what their parents believe and simply
just going along with something or literally wandering around the darkness hoping
that what they believe is somehow true and that somehow in the end of all things,
when this life ends, that they'll find out that it is actually true.
What's interesting though, is that John says something in the very end of his gospel
that starts to speak to us about really what faith actually is.
And it's in John chapter 20 verses 30 and 31.
And John says this, Jesus did many other miracles or miraculous signs in the
presence of his disciples, which are not recorded in this book.
But these are written that you may believe that Jesus is the Christ, the Son
of God, and that by believing you may have life in his name.
What's interesting is what John says here is that these miraculous signs, all
of these things that John has recorded in his gospel are so that you might believe.
We're given reasons. And what's fascinating about the Gospel of John is these seven
miraculous signs that John gives, starting with Jesus turning water into wine
and then ending with this magnitude kind of a miracle with the raising of
Lazarus. And then if you want to include the eighth one of Jesus's own resurrection
is that time after time, John sets it up so that we see increasing
in measure all these signs that Jesus is exactly who he says he
is. And this is what we want students to actually get.
That biblical faith is trust based on evidence.
And that translates really into a deeper relationship.
I mean, think about the relationships that you have.
You don't just blindly trust somebody that you don't know.
But the more you get to know somebody, the more you trust them.
The more you trust them, the deeper that relationship starts to go.
And this is sort of how relationships work.
It's no different than with our relationship with Christ.
The more we know who He is, the more we know about what's going on and what the
gospel is, the more we can trust and the more reason we have to trust in what
God is doing through Christ. And the more that we do that, the deeper our
relationship with him goes. And this is exactly why we start
in this lesson with this idea of your student's trust between friends.
We want them to get that sense of what that looks like because our best and deepest
relationships are built on a sense of trust, a deep sense of trust.
And we have that because that person has either continually provided
reasons to trust them, or maybe not reasons to trust them, right?
So we want our students to be able to see how that works.
And what's really even more fascinating, I think, is when we start thinking about
what faith is and how this works, we naturally kind of find ourselves in Hebrews 11,
right? Hebrews 11:1. Now, faith is being sure of what we hope for and certain of
what we do not see. This is what the ancients were commended for.
And then the writer of Hebrews goes through that huge wall of faith of all these
people that had the right kind of faith.
And we use this verse as sort of the foundational piece of what faith means, right?
Being sure of what we hope for and certain of what we do not see.
Well, that word certain, the word actually means or the idea it has
with it, the idea of a foundation or substructure.
So think of it this way. It's a basement.
the idea that the writer is talking about is the basement in your home when you
walk downstairs into your basement if you have one or if you've ever walked into a
basement you generally don't fear that the whole house is going to cave in
on you right because you've walked down to a basement has these huge metal beams and
these metal poles and they're driven into the cement into the ground and the whole
house is being held up by these beams and this basement and when you walk
downstairs, you don't think anything of it.
Why? Because the house is built on a solid foundation.
And if foundation in a house is cracked, the house is starting to be no good and you
can't really do anything in the house until you fix the foundation.
So that's what the writer is saying.
It's so sure, so fundamental that you can walk into a house and feel
totally confident so much so that you don't even think about it.
That's what faith is. It's that foundational piece of what we do not see.
It's assurance of it. And in fact, if you take it one step deeper, the root word
comes from the idea of an idea or one who stands
immovable. It cannot be moved at all.
One who is so rock solid and so dug into a foundation that it
can't be moved. That is what our faith is.
And that's what we want students to be able to see.
I mean, think about it for a second.
I was just thinking about this the other day.
Why did Jesus keep his wounds?
Why would Jesus, he's Jesus. He resurrects.
And yet in the end of John's gospel, he shows Thomas his wounds.
Thomas wants to see them. He wants to see for himself what it is that Jesus,
why? It's Jesus. He's resurrected what more evidence do you need
right but Jesus keeps his wounds and I've always found that really fascinating
that of all things that Jesus could have done be like well I'm going to fix these
wounds because why would I want to have these holes in my wrist and this gash in my
side why would I want to keep those one more reason
even if it was just for Thomas one more reason to show that this
is who I am, and I've done exactly what I said I was going to do.
So faith. We want our students to really understand the deep roots of faith,
that it's not wandering in the darkness, but it's assurance and evidence of belief.
So our small group time should be something that students can sort of take a step
back and think about it and discuss with each other what it really means
to have faith. And I want your students to start, and you should encourage your
students to start thinking about, well, do I have my own faith?
Or am I still just believing what my parents believed or what other people have told
me to believe? Or am I starting to now believe things on my own based on what I'm
now discovering? And that starts with asking your students have they considered
the evidence? Have they considered all of the tools that are in here especially
that God has given us to figure out is what Jesus
did and what God is doing and the whole of salvation history, is that enough?
So what we're talking about is finding a space where your students can start
to make their faith their own it's easy for us as leaders to stand up in front of
a bunch of students and tell them about our faith and read through Scripture and
give them an interpretation of what our faith looks like and what faith they ought
to have based on our faith but it's a whole different thing and the thing that we
want you to start to encourage students so this transfer of what we're telling
them to believe and what they believe based on the evidence that they're
discovering on their own begins to happen is we want you to create a space where
students can invest, they can pursue on their own.
To go back to the idea of questions, they can ask the right questions or ask any
questions for that matter so that the evidence that's here in Scripture will just
come right off the page and into their lives.
That's the kind of faith that sticks.
That's the kind of faith that they'll take with them to college.
That's the kind of faith that we want them to have.
We don't want just them to accept what we're telling them.
We want them to discover that what we're telling them is actually true.
So, three things to keep in mind.
One, drive home the fact that biblical faith is not without evidence.
Biblical faith is not without evidence.
Number two, that Jesus has taken significant time and energy to give us that
evidence. And finally, number three, for students considering the evidence, it opens
the door to a much deeper and more meaningful relationship with the creator of the
world.